vite jean-pierre colombiès porte parole
de l'union des policiers nationaux
bonsoir jean pierre colombiès merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous sur arte
france pour décrypter ce qui semble être
un nouvel attentat terroriste le parquet
antiterroriste a été saisie cela veut
dire qu'il ya des éléments qui
corroborent cette thèse du terrorisme
oui bonsoir oui tout à fait d'après les
éléments dont je dispose on est
clairement dans un acte en rapport avec
avec la religion tout simplement donc
avec une motivation qu'on connaît
maintenant
l'anc elle dira plus précisément ce
qu'il en est maintenant oui c'est sûr on
est clairement dans un acte aux
motivations qu'on ne connaît que trop
bien qu'ils sont qui sont cultuelle on
commence sur un petit peu plus dans la
mesure où les éléments que j'ai pour
l'instant sont un petit peu fragile mais
on peut on peut on peut on s'avance pas
trop en disant que oui on est dans une
dynamique terroriste au lait puisque
l'homme a été abattu
les démineurs sont également sur place
on parle de l'éventualité d'un port de
ceinture d'explosifs en tout cas le mode
opératoire il semblerait qu'il y ait eu
une on ne connaît pas encore le nom de
la victime une décapitation
c'est un mode opératoire connu dans ce
type d'acte terroriste
oui malheureusement oui c'est pas la
première fois sous les huit chefs
d'entreprise qui a été tué par son
employé qui qui exhibe et la tête de son
exploit la tête de son acte de son
patron juste avant de faire un selphy
vous pourriez rien d'étonnant ya rien de
nouveau sous le soleil
il ya une dynamique date d'actes
terroristes à motivation religieuse la
décapitation est le geste rituel par
excellence on l'a vu en france on l'a vu
à l'étranger s'il s'est lui hissé ces
courants et c'est en tout cas la
démonstration que quelques sur les
discours
le danger est là la pression est là les
discours haineux sont là on peut se
donner bonne conscience en disant que
tout va très bien sous le soleil de
france mais non ça va pas bien
ça n'a pas bien parce que les individus
sont prêts à tuer au nom de dieu
et que rien ne peut raisonner ces
individus là qu'on ne veuille ou pas on
peut tenir des discours consensuel à
longueur de temps pendant des heures
mais quand vous avez des personnes qui
sont convaincus que leurs actes l'acte
criminel qui commettent leur permettra
d'avoir une récompense divine vous
n'avez aucune possibilité de les
raisonner
alors on est vendredi également
peut-être est-ce un élément
supplémentaire pour corroborer cette
thèse puisque c'est une journée de
prière pour les croyants musulmans
ce mode opératoire cet individu a été
c'est la police municipale qui est
d'abord donné l alerte la police anti
criminalité s'est ensuite rendu sur
place elle n'avait pas d'autre choix que
d'abattre l'individu selon vous c'est la
procédure une question de procédure que
c'est une question de légitime défense
comme on est simplement vous êtes un
seul individu qui a quand même décapité
une personne on parle pas d'une boîte
fait classique c'est pas des violences
volontaires légère c'est un meurtre le
meurtre particulièrement cruel très
violent vous êtes face à un homme armé
alors mais d'un couteau qu'il y ait
encore des velléités de poursuivre cette
dynamique meurtrière je vois pas quelle
autre solution on peut en voir puisqu'il
aurait aussi menacé les policiers il ya
des sommations et ensuite plusieurs
coups de feu dont qui ont neutralisé
l'assaillant comment va se dérouler
l'anc est à présent il y aura
nécessairement une enquête sur le ces
motivations sur sa personnalité bien
évidemment qui est il pour quelle raison
at il commis ce meurtre
il ya quelques éléments comme ça qu'ils
sont parvenus ça demanderait que
confirmer ont selon une dynamique nous
faut plus de caricatures de 2,2 de
gestes ou de propos qui ont été tenus
tout ça ça doit être confirmée donc je
parle avec beaucoup de réserve bien sûr
bien sûr du mans la seule chose dont on
est certain si voilà c'est que l'acte
est symbolique il rituel donc ya pas de
doute quant à la motivation de cet
individu à quoi il a été abattu jamais
dire que ces deux risques de la chose et
c'est ce que souhaite aussi souvent ces
terroristes
de mourir en martyrs gérald darmanin lui
rentrer d'urgence pour se rendre sur
place bien évidemment on sait qui on
connaît le contexte dans la menace est
toujours là et on voit rien rien n'est
possible en tout cas pour semble-t-il
pour les arrêter ces individus je crois
qu'il faut vraiment connaître leur
mentalité leur culture leur font
lorsqu'ils mystique c'est bien gentil
d'avoir des discours très consensuel sur
l'appartenance à la communauté nationale
mais tout ça vole en éclats dès lors que
vous avez des individus qui se réfère à
une religion qui placent des préceptes
qui est morceaux qui sont enseignés au
delà des règles de la vie commune
pourrait te dire tout ce que vous voulez
comme discours partir il se sera pas
entendue la difficulté c'est souvent des
hommes seuls qui agissent avec des armes
on que l'on peut se procurer assez
facilement finalement alors des hommes
seuls certes après il faut voir si il a
été il évolue dans un réseau d'
influence avec un ancrage très influent
qui pourrait avoir incité encouragé à le
faire via une solitude bien sûr qu'il ya
souvent des actes sur solitaire ça on a
vu on avait plusieurs fois pour se
radicaliser pas nécessaire d'appartenir
à une structure bien organisés suffit
d'aller sur internet allées dallées
intercepté des vidéos de guerrière qui
incite au djihad tient sida au meurtre
tout simplement aucun chat un chat le
budget c'est pas que la démarche
intérieure c'est aussi le combat à locon
par contre entre les impliquent entre
les infidèles auprès des relapse quand
toute une série très bien décider
d'ailleurs d'individus qui sont contre
la réduction donc tout ça dans quatre le
déterminera pour autant voilà le
résultat aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a
quelqu'un qui s'était coupé la tête au
nom de dieu par un individu s'il ya
suffisamment de motivation pour aller
ensuite se jeter contre des policiers et
mourir et donc comme vous l'avez dit
fort justement mourir en martyr c'est
plié le est la plus belle mort que l'on
puisse souhaiter pour un pour le croyant
heureusement sur le low profile on ne
connaît pas encore évidemment l'identité
de cet individu mais le fait de
décapiter quelqu'un on sait que le père
âme elle aussi avait été avait subi le
même sort à saint-etienne du rouvray
le 26 juillet 2016 le fait de décapiter
quelqu'un il faut avoir quand même un
certain aplomb et s'éteint un message
envoyé aussi aux citoyens français
il faut tout simplement voir une fois
bien accroché avoir une forte conviction
religieuse
c'est un acte rituel symbolique qui va
grandir celui là comme il l'a fait donc
c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas attendre de
le dire et de le cour de comptes de
contrition il n'y a pas de compter sur
avoir c'est un acte glorieux pour celui
qu'il a commis il faut bien avoir en
tête et lorient grâce à sa famille je
rappelle que l'individu qui a acquis à
attaquer dans les anciens locaux de
charlie hebdo a été félicité par
l'ensemble du village dont il est issu
donc ça fait partie d'une culture de
jihad global
pour certains en tout cas un pack tous
tous les musulmans bien évidemment mais
pour une certaine partie de la
communauté très radicaliser c'est
quelque chose de doux glorieux merci
beaucoup jean-pierre colombiès on va en
reparler bien sûr quand on aura
davantage d'informations et merci en
tout cas pour cette première analyse en
direct sur notre antenne